[Music]
hi everybody welcome to chess for
rookies I'm back tanned rested and ready
for you at home there also are people
here if you can call them people that
I'm grandma Esther Ben Feingold and
you're not as you all know I'm opening a
chess Center in Atlanta in September but
before I do that I'm doing chess videos
here probably about 10 this month now we
don't have Ben Simon but we have his
replacement
ruthless indoor doofus okay aka the scab
okay and we're going to make some videos
now this is the two o'clock class twice
as good as the one o'clock class then I
would make fun of the one o'clock class
non-stop like I always do but I think we
have a ringer in here
that gives in both classes so the one
o'clock class is great okay so first
this you're going to look at is this one
we're going to look at seven positions
today because Simon is lucky right kids
let's see if some of them were like
nodding their head diagonally I think
they think they're bishops okay now in
this position material is equal both
sides have all the same everything but
white decided it was better to be a
piece up there not be a piece up okay
the kids are scratching their brows in a
vain attempt to understand the situation
and why play the move Knight takes e5
man recommended by Emeril and now as you
kids all noticed white is up a piece
that none of them notice did yeah just
like you would home I think they are at
home all right so my question to you and
the audience and you in this audience is
how does black get his fees back now
before you give the wrong answer gonna
give the wrong answer later I'll give
you one of the wrong answers that you
can give me your wrong answer okay
most of you are like
oh and the bathrooms over there you're
like Knight takes Knight I got my peas
back and then you start doing the wave
and everything okay but actually white
just takes that that you're down at
night you're all talking too bad you got
nothing okay so black has to do
something else
black wants to win back is night but
taking it right away doesn't work now
who wants to give me the wrong answer
you pretty some pretty evidence are you
incorrect
anyone else oh you didn't say anything
yet yeah f-five is correct are you
feeling okay you don't to see doctor
anything yeah okay so f5 is correct or
as Donald Trump would call it incorrect
okay that's peak news f5 attacking the
Queen right now just white want to lose
his queen look I mean you want to lose
your queen banging the guy who has white
here the guy who has life is not one of
this is queen I can prove it I was white
this game was played in France before
you were born
hey can you make more noise there Thanks
okay you can Wow okay so that's actually
not one of the kids that was our special
guest that when he was a kid his mom and
the doctor said he was special okay and
his brother works at the chef's club and
he used to work at the Chess Club so
okay this videos we shown in a week so I
want alive in them all right now is it
possible for whites of movies Queen and
keep a defense on his name you with the
wrong answer
see that kid listed he gave the wrong
answer
good job queen bee five does defend the
night unfortunately the rook can take
your queen followed by lots of crying
right and if the rook takes your queen
you have to go to one o'clock class just
go back in time it's not easy to do or
you could go forward a week but you
probably wouldn't do that because at one
o'clock next week you'll be busy buying
the Father's Day present for the two
o'clock class so you can see how you
wouldn't do that yeah okay so anybody
else have another answer anyone Bueller
yeah the answer is you were sort of like
nah that's right you can't there's
nothing you can do if white moves his
Queen there's nowhere he can move the
defense is not yet so I was white and
I'm as greedy as they come so I took
something what did I take with his Queen
what did I do
you with the right answer right you
meant b7 so we're still right queen's
eggs b7 and then my opponent took the
night as we discussed and I took this
blonde so White's up two pawns the white
didn't castle yet okay and whites queen
is a little funny so the computer engine
actually says this is equal of the
whites up to pawns and I won hooray okay
but it was very very very important that
black played f5 if he didn't play up
five he would be down a night and said
he wasn't down a night but I still won
so what is he doing he's crying right
that's because he's French all right
let's go to the next game and see if you
guys do even better with that can't do
worse all right this is the game Rufus
versus doofus I think you were playing
your brother or something all right this
is a game I played a long time ago in a
country that no longer exists true story
yeah when I played the game it was
called Czechoslovakia now what's it
called
nobody knows
anybody you with the wrong answer that's
correct it was the Czech Republic I also
would have accepted Slovakia but it's
the Czech Republic where the tournament
was okay now this game was played before
Barney the dinosaur was famous but and
even so we both tried to checkmate each
other I check me you you checkmate me
lucky for me he's the worst player in
history right no I think that's what
happened all right now in this position
it's white to move and I was white if
it's black to move black would play
Queen a1 me or rook a one mate he
probably lose on time trying to figure
out which way to meet me but it's not
his turn it's my turn
BAM so what move did I make where I try
to meet him before he mates me okay you
at home incorrect you in real life
rip take g4 check that's what I played
okay now we're going to vote okay you
can vote for a number or you can vote
for Pat Buchanan most people who vote
for Buchanan do so by mistake but you
can still do it okay
black has the god of check because I
said so Black has more than one will you
go to chat I'm serious right let's count
how many ways you can go out of check
and then see who's right you guys can do
it too at home so you're black and you
don't want to be in check you have to
get out of check how many ways can you
do it
raise your hand if you know you three
that's pretty close you four five three
four five five does somebody have an
answer that's not three four or five
okay everybody says three four or five
I have no ID on the teacher I don't know
let's count one two three four five
there's three King moves
that's probably why some people said
three now you can block
tonight that you can block with a queen
right if your blog was a queen you might
lose your queen right so probably he
didn't do that if you block with a
knight then every move is checkmate
queen be a queen c8 and queen be a all
checkmate
which one do you like let's do da it's
close to the king now most you don't
think that's checkmate because you
belong into one o'clock class but to
actually check me the bishop stops the
King from moving and the rook stops the
knight from moving that's checkmate
so did my opponent block with his Queen
or nine now if he plays King f8 this is
also checkmate so you didn't do that
either so what did he do thanks for
asking
he plays King h7 I'll take this pawn
with check then this is checkmate and
this is checkmate
and if you want to play Knight g7 the
computer won't let you see how it won't
let me
you know why it won't let me it's been
right the vicious King tonight so my
opponent didn't do any of that okay now
it's time for my two sweetest words of
the English language default what move
did black play the only move I didn't
look at it what's that King h8 what
feeling we didn't look at and then I
gave up oh wait a minute no I didn't i
won
is that better than giving up if for you
at home the classes like out oh ok so
instead I put my opponent in check did I
check on be a c8 or da what louder da in
fact they all win but Jia twins quick
quicker is better because I wanted to go
eat there the dollar was strong then in
check check 1990 ok
my opponent played the best move can any
of you find it or is it too hard they
all said it was too hard
what if black 2 is in check what do you
think I got a point better King age 7
now I'm going to shock the class did you
all wear your shock resistant clothes
because we're going to be shocking you
ready to be shocked white has made in
one move even I'm shocked and I played
it you in the back with the right answer
yeah I saw him play before so I knew he
had the right answer Queen age 4 check
me confusing half the kids in the class
what ends a guy who's filming it ok
check me because the Knights pinned as
was pointed out before so I checked
waited my opponent then he checkmated me
so was it draw right now ridiculous
right ok so I was very lucky that came
if we go all the way back in this
position was that a good move my
opponent played rip takes a four yeah it
was good for me because i checkmated him
if this rook was on the back row
protecting his king i couldn't all those
Queen checks that made it up so he
shouldn't have played rook takes a 4
then I check me to them he throws me to
checkmate me but he was not quite right
close okay how come I'm white one game
black the other game who made this file
okay this is a game I played in
Reykjavik in 1990 is Reykjavik your
favorite City yeah
[Music]
somebody raised their hand something
where Reykjavik is you incorrect
nice okay as a capital otter yeah
Reykjavik okay it's an Iceland your
favorite country right what famous world
chess champion died in Iceland it's the
only one you heard of that helps do you
like I heard of somebody yeah you like I
heard of Fisher him right Bobby Fisher
he lived the last year sold his life in
Iceland and since he was a chess player
all old was he when he died all chess
players have to die at this age it's a
rule and 80 where'd you get them with
number 80 from you just made it up there
is no such number it goes 79 81 kids
I'll give you a hint how many squares
are on a chess board and that's how old
he was when he died 64 and he died in
Iceland and Iceland is where he became
the world champion because he beat your
favorite world champion to become the
world champion who did Fischer beating
you with the right answer you look
really confident ah can they hear there
can they hear what he said yes
I like your answer you showed moxie you
aah
all right let's vote which answer is
worse more fear cos far on hold on cuz
Faro was alive when Fischer became world
champion but but he was 9 hmm they're
equally bad answers gives you a give
yourselves a hand
yeah nobody he raises he was like really
confident I you with the right answer
ah your answer is almost right you're so
close
you tend to walk champion they never
heard of that's good nobody knows who
Fischer be the people at home were like
ooh me
I'm not calling on you the correct
answer is Boris Spassky your favorite
player no now for a trick question is
Boris passkey alive that's why it's a
trick question he's alive
see I tricked them they're like wow how
could be alive
now he's about 80 like you said yeah
yeah boo that's good like that
blue he's like okay now this game was
played in Iceland in 1990 by me okay
and my opponent played Queen 8th floor
and I was like guess he was like quiet
I'm playing notice I could take his a
night but then he would take my queen
and I'm gonna go back to the 1 o'clock
class I would be able to audience right
isn't Queen takes Knight a terrible move
okay so my opponents like Queen a4 and
he was like Queen takes Knight still a
terrible move I still take your queen
and I was like oh man I wish his Knight
wasn't there so I could take his other
night and then I went like this mmm
now today I would never figure out the
answer but in 1990 I was good
were you good in 1991 what kind of
excuse is that okay so what moves did I
make so I could kick this a night out
and then take this knife for freeze you
with the right answer I play g5 BAM
notice I'm attacking his Bishop because
I said so did he let me take his bishop
what's the only same square for his
Bishop g3 hey now I could attack his
Knight g4 yes you see how this tonight
is defending that night see what I'm
saying
and then that Knights attacked I'm
attacking all his knights right and
that's because I used to live in Ann
Arbor so I know how to work on my knight
modes nothing what Bob Seger Night Moves
never Bob Seger you ever heard the song
Night Moves that that seals your fate
seal he never in stealing their field oh
all right I thought something else was
the worst person who ever lived but you
give it a fighting chance over here all
right
so even the song even says it's funny
how the night moves but he's five months
up now
all right so if the night moves I take
this tonight so first what's the first
thing he did the first thing
say it again loud he cries that's right
what's funny is he sort of did cry here
I'm not even kidding yeah I played g5
and he put his head down and shook his
head a long time because he's like man
I'm losing a piece that's terrible
Grandmaster
I can't lose a piece now what's funny
about this game is after he lost a piece
he quit chess but became a lawyer you
can't make that up because that happened
and what was his name I gave you a lot
of information about him now you never
heard of him
you never heard of at home either
ferdinand Heller's you got nothing okay
so I go to the internet type in
Ferdinand howlers and it'll say file not
found
all right so now I win a piece so he
resigned later in this position was
Queen a for a good move no it was good
for me because I want a piece yes
that'll teach him to undefended night
boo become a lawyer okay next game
hooray
now this is one of my favorites this is
just the right level for the class if
you will 700 points better okay so in
this position I have a bishop in the
knight and my opponent has a rook
otherwise everything is the same okay
what's better a bishop and a knight or a
rook a bishop in tonight that's the two
o'clock in sir good job okay my opponent
he thought he was winning he was like
I'm gonna win and he played rugby one
attacking my queen should I want to take
him to take my queen now I'm going to
move my cleanaway because I don't want
to lose my queen yeah but let me I'm
trying to teach over here okay so I'm
trying to think let's just save square
for my queen is that a save square by
here are any of these squares safe now
man if I move my queen of those squares
he's going to take my queen right
do I want to lose my queen now so I have
two squares C 2 and C 3 those are the
safe squares unfortunately let's go to
one of them he plays rook takes b7 check
how do I get out of check d6 somebody
said then check me and white has the
advantage because white one also I could
go to c6 I could and then check me or I
could give my queen away those are all
good choices
I could lose my cleaner get checkmated
okay so if I don't move my queen he
takes my queen if I move my queen
he checkmates me so he was like oh boy
I'm gonna win look at me and I'm like
quiet I'm thinking lucky for me Black is
winning he has one move that wins
otherwise he loses now what a world
okay and the reason I'm winning is his
king is trapped in the corner perfect
for getting checkmated unfortunately for
me he's got two rooks defending the back
row so I can't check meet him but I can
try to checkmate him I can't try to
check if I can try to try you with the
right answer you're too confident work
a3 says the person who saw this before
what you deny everything you deny
nothing he's like was that I need have
you seen this before
what yeah of course
okay so I played rug to a3 BAM
and then he started crying
exactly when I teach chef teach us when
I coach at the world youth all they're
all kids and their opponents are all
kids make sense now when the game is
over I analyze the games of the American
kids because I'm the American coach and
when they come up to show me their game
I said did your opponent cry
50/50 yeah world championship half the
kids cried
they must have read my book cry like a
green minister
none of them read it terrible okay
you guys must have read my book don't
read a book like a grandmaster which I
also okay so what happens to be taste my
queen I take the rock and then I win
pray for me let's say he doesn't take my
queen what's the big deal the big deal
is I'm going to take his rook and
there's nothing he can do about it do
you feel bad for him yeah now did I get
lucky and I just found this move or I
saw it a long time ago
you'll never know because I'm probably
lying now I thought about five moves ago
okay then I went here he's like no so he
like checked me once and then I think I
went here or did I go here I forgot
where I wanted I'm with my king
somewhere then he gave up and then he
read my book give up like a grandmaster
it's a really short book you know why it
was written by Nigel short okay next now
this game is very interesting because
it's played by the two best Peters in
the world if you want somebody named
Peter who's good at chess look no
further
Peter Lake oh and Peters fiddler okay if
Spitler has lost this game he would have
been on the roof right Fiddler on the
Roof now the kids got it now you can get
it home either anyway in this position
black has a good position but he made
the worst move ever
but he had a good excuse they were doing
something you've never heard of
they were playing blindfold they weren't
looking so they weren't looking at the
board and they would just see their
moves out loud like pawn to e4 Knight to
f6 and they would remember the position
in their head because of that they
didn't play perfect okay and this is a
good example of that black played rook
g5 and eventually black one okay that
blacks position was pretty good however
white should've won
White has a winning move here but since
he was playing blindfold he didn't see
it because he was blindfold so he didn't
see it
nothing okay couple kid got it okay so
what's the winning move for white and
actually this is a very interesting
what's it called word vocabulary word
chess term it's called the clearance
sacrifice okay you're clearing something
out of the way like your throat right
now you got nothing
wait who says they see it no lying in my
class look to be that is the clear and
sacrifice but I'll take it when you play
rook to b6 you did it so you could play
Queen f7 Shaq didn't you say yeah but if
you play rook to b6 I can defend f7 for
example rook f8
why don't you threaten Queen f7 but
force me to take your rug you with the
right answer because I gave it away
yeah red g6 BAM you're supposed to say
I'm ng6 I just said b6 by accident I'll
believe you yeah there you go good
notice that it's check because I said so
right now in this position white wants
to jump over his rook and play check but
even though he's rated 2750 that's still
not allowed you got to be at least 2800
to do that
then which one so he played road g6
check now his rooks not there anymore so
he can play Queen f7 next to move right
rook g6 check would win the game
immediately but he didn't play it then
after the game they were like dude you
could have played route g6 check and he
was like dude with a mean I speak
Hungarian okay so if you take with a
pawn then you get checkmated BAM if you
take with the other pawn it's the same
thing what you save upon clean check and
make it if you take with a ruck it's the
same thing they easy to analyze and me I
won't let me there we go now you don't
have to take the rook you can play King
f8 that's pretty safe
I'll wait it isn't or you can play King
h8 and now you actually have to find a
good move not your specialty can you
find a good move for white recommended
by knee for those of you at home one
kids raising their hand one there's like
400 kids in this room you correct Queen
f6 check the winning move also known as
checkmate right check me it's a good
move oh you're taking notes I'll let you
write that down oh you're taking notes
at home checkmate is a good move once if
like me okay chapter rook g6 check Peter
like Oh would have won he didn't play
with g6 check he defended his bishop
boom it what's funny about that before
black playing rook g5 that wouldn't have
worked let's say black played a silly
move that's pretty good for a silly move
threatened Rick c1 okay now Rick g6
doesn't work because I take with a queen
and my queen defends f7 pray but he
plays rook g5 allowing White's to play
Rick g6 check did white play red g6
check now see he lost ah too bad did he
forget about it now probably not
alright we're adults amid problem
there's one way up to this
oh yeah that's without Andra okay now
raise your hand and tell me who the
world chess champion is you right now
raise your hand and tell me who had
white in this game you right what are
you just quoting yourself right yeah
you're looking at that too right so and
the player with black was me hooray for
me
or maybe him okay so two months ago
possibly three I can't remember I played
Magnus Carlsen for the pro chess league
championship which team won my team or
his team I know that my t1 because the
trophies of the Chess Club when you walk
in there's my name on it
you can go look after class I can prove
it okay our team won that means that I
beat Magnus right no you know what
happened when I beat him I had to wake
up and apologize none of the kids none
of them none of them got it nothing
nothing okay
so in this position you'll notice white
is upon a head correct it's true okay
and my rook is really well placed in the
corner here that way if I resign they're
already set up for the next game okay so
I activated my rook now Magnus Carlsen
being the highest rated player in the
world and the world champion knows
something you don't
it's a secret if you checkmate your
opponent you win yeah so he was like how
do I check make this fine gold character
he's like wow I check here then we'll
escape if I check here then we'll escape
if I check here then we'll take my
knight he was like how do I make this
guy he's like oh I have it when I go
here white plays light black plays King
f5 I won't let him play King f5 so
Magnus played he for
now if he could move again he would play
checkmate the truth hurts right so I put
magnets in check
did you checkmate me no you got a check
now I can't check him anymore
darn one check that's pretty good okay
so how did I stop Magnus from playing
rugby six checkmate how do I defend d6
you at least three years old at least
yeah yeah I could play Bishop e7 I could
now he wins my bishop with a series of
moves he checks me and I play King f6
because I have to and he checks to me
again or he could play e5 check and I
have to go here and he takes my bishop
ok so I thought checkmate without losing
my bishop temporarily you with the right
answer
ah I said right answer you said Rick v8
why you making me look bad in front of
my people if words d8
that's not defended as much also you
forgot to stop checkmate
you forgot ok also I could take the rook
but check makes better you with the
right answer
resign what do I ever lose while baby in
this game you Russ b6 BAM ok so I
stopped all his route g6 mate
ok and he was like man this guy's top in
route d6 me I have an idea
Knight d4 me is that me why isn't it me
because he takes it so he made a move
where I couldn't take it
what did he do
I least thought my bishop from taking
that night louder
he fired now if it was White's move
Knight d4 is me right you agree and also
plunk things bishop wins a bishop so
he's threatening pawn takes Bishop and
he threatening Knight d4 me so what's
the first thing I did cried you this is
a c5 is the best move I didn't play that
was the best move then he takes my
bishop and then I cry again that's
double crying yeah so instead of giving
my bishop away and instead of getting
needed what did I do
I resigned
yeah if Magnus was like this guy's a
great master and I was like quiet
rawr and then I said magnets which team
won oh snap so there was a four game
match there were four of us all four of
us played four games
Magnus got four points the rest of his
team did not give four points the rest
of his team played 12 games they got
three points three out of 12 solid so
they got seven because four plus three
is seven
just a second one kids making sure I'm
right is that right yeah he said I was
right and if it's 16 games four times
four 16 if they got seven what did we
get ah right I asked the German guy and
he said nine so we won nine two seven
nine is more than seven so we won yeah
and what did our team win how much money
the protest Lee give us protest Lee you
know the year way old us you know the
answer yeah what's the answer
twenty thousand dollars yeah no fear
sound of fear to me
I got destroyed in the twenty thousand
great did I get all 20 thousand or did
they give some of it to Leslie so if
anybody heard of Wesley so wow I have to
class he's the second highest rated
player in the world although he's third
now but he was second before Norway
kramnik second big switch okay
now normally I would end the lecture and
a game I lost but I had a really funny
win two months ago against Ali
Jero but don't call his name hey I said
don't call his name
alright now as for usual I had a
fantastic Bishop on f1 they can't move
ok here we both have a Queen rook minor
piece three pawns in a king it's one of
the first times in my chest career we
both had a kid no it wasn't that
now one thing you didn't notice is that
black is in check so he moved his King
smart right no okay now about seven or
eight moves ago he offered me a draw and
I declined and we got this position now
White's winning White has one winning
move it's too hard for the one o'clock
class it's too hard for you at home but
maybe you kids can find it what's the
winning move for white I made this one
that he started crying well he's a
grandmaster so he was crying before you
were born
now what's funny about me and Alejandro
is I became a grandmaster at the age of
40 you ever heard of forty actually
probably haven't okay he became a
grandmaster at the age of fifteen that's
younger than I was right so he'll never
be forty not even close
terrible and he's from your favorite
country because half of you have heard
of it half of them or less than half and
you guys are insulting you right he's
right in front of you
Costa Rica you should have heard of
Costa Rica because of the last World Cup
right kids like what what's a World Cup
what sport am I talking about you sack
remember Costa Rica they did well they
have like seven people in no country but
they still killed a team of 11 that's
good good job okay so Alejandro is from
Costa Rica
so what's see does you live in st. Louis
everybody lives in st. Louis even him
most of you do yeah all the grandmasters
go to st. Louis because we have chess
here we have like this white and we have
a camera and we have a board in Costa
Rica
nothing he's got dirt yeah seems like
playing chess with the dirt they're like
why your Grand Master go to America is
that what happened that's that's yeah
okay
so what would did I make and then whites
winning it's a term you've never heard
before
it's a pin ah now somebody has it who
has is yeah whoever sees it raise your
hand what's the answer
Bishop takes c4 that's risky because
you'll take my bishop and I'll cry he
could take with a queen or with the rook
that's a dangerous move too dangerous
for me I played a slightly safer
Louisville only slightly what did I do
could taking advantage of a pin although
that answer actually was the right piece
just the wrong square but who seizes
what I can't see this lights in my eyes
you with the right answer Bishop h3 did
he take my bishop and then I took his
queen why not that sounds good to me
okay so he doesn't take my bishop but
I'm attacking his pawn he has a lot of
defenses to his pawn zero that's a lot
okay so he's like I can't defend my pawn
when so he played ripped b7 I think I
took his pawn and he checked me now
we're going to see how smart the two
o'clock classes
how many legal moves does white have you
what a thousand deaths interesting
answer you four
can you can you walk these people to the
one o'clock class let go back in time
somehow yeah you it's the right answer
the most common answers one thousand I
know talking ever again like when I die
no talking you too okay so I'm in check
because I'm in check and I have to get
out of check that's why you're the two
o'clock class I could take your up or I
can move my king
I need the move you wouldn't suspect so
figure out that movie wouldn't suspect
and then say that one that's the right
answer
you right King age - that's what I did
BAM
Rick's a crook also wins but King age
two is better now most of you are
confused you came in confused when I
you're more confused
you're like why'd you give your rook
away what are you doing what's going on
around here now White has one winning
move but it's really winning extra
winning plus tax
what's the winning move for white it's a
double discovered triple whoops you
Bishop h5 check notice how it's checked
right and I'm attacking his queen
that's called me winning his queen right
he didn't want to lose his queen so he
didn't do that he played Queen e1
threatening Queen h1 checkmate what a
mean guy so if it was his move he would
win with Queen h1 he'd also in with
Queen G 1 followed by mate next move
okay luckily it's my move otherwise I
would lose by the way I can stop both
checkmates Queens you want to by taking
his rook and then he meets me over here
check and queen g2 mate there's a lot of
ways to lose entrust I decided I'd win
that sounded like a better idea
so I played Rick
and Shaq and he was like oh man your
queen and Ricker meeting me and I was
like quiet we're playing notice how he's
in check right if he goes here check me
if he goes here check me if he goes the
g8 then I have many checkmates I could
play Bishop takes tonight or queen aged
seven I don't know what you prefer I
think we had sevens quicker so we'll do
that and then checkmate
so after rook a7 he played your favorite
move it's not really a move he resigned
right I meet you you don't meet me all
right and as gene Wilder said at the
beginning of Young Frankenstein class is
dismissed
now you can clap
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]